fue la primera monarca británica en
visitar india tras su independencia en
1961 isabel 2a y su marido felipe fueron
los invitados de honor del presidente en
el desfile del día de la república
recorriendo el taj mahal rindiendo
homenaje a mahatma gandhi e incluso
disfrutando de un paseo en elefante con
enormes multitudes ayudándoles a cada
paso
en su tercera y última visita en 1997
con motivo del 50 aniversario de la
independencia de y de la colonia
británica la recepción se había enfriado
en ese viaje la reina abordó por primera
vez lo que llamó episodios difíciles de
la historia colonial de india citando la
masacre de 1919 en avistar cuando las
tropas británicas abrieron fuego contra
una multitud desarmada matando a cientos
de personas pero la monarca no llegó a
emitir una disculpa más de dos décadas
después de su última visita la muerte de
la reina isabel fue recibida con gran
indiferencia en las calles de la capital
india tengo sentimientos muy neutros
hacia la reina no es ni malo ni bueno
porque una vez fuimos gobernados por los
británicos y por culpa de su familia
tuvimos que tolerar la esclavitud
durante muchos años y muchas grandes
masacres han ocurrido en india por culpa
de su familia
ya no nos importa la realeza porque
gobernar nuestro propio país a nuestra
manera es mejor que seguir al rey ya la
reina y el primer ministro indio se
adentra modi ha tratado de purgar el
país de los símbolos coloniales sin
embargo se apresuró a dar una respuesta
oficial ofreciendo sus condolencias y
alabando la dignidad y la decencia de
isabel segunda mientras india observaba
un día de luto nacional algunos
expresaban su tristeza por el
fallecimiento de la reina y sus
pensamientos para su sucesor y estamos
pintando un cuadro del rey carlos para
felicitarle que se ha convertido en el
rey de inglaterra y estamos muy
contentos hasta ahora no ha habido
grandes presiones para que india
abandone la commowealth pero la muerte
de la reina ha reavivado las preguntas
sobre el destino del diamante koh y nur
extraído en india ahora se encuentra en
la corona que una vez llevó la madre de
la reina y ha sido tendencia en las
redes sociales indias con muchos
pidiendo su regreso